[Musique]
sean penn dylan peine et toute l'équipe
non
[Musique]
qui vont être avec nous mais là on nous
avons des membres du jury qui sont en
train de monter les marches deux fois
mylène farmer je vois arriver je vois à
mélanie laurent
ils ont la t3 connaissez en a pas trop
d'en parler dans la démarche générale on
leur demande
après des questions mais
jamais l'équipe jamais jamais jamais
jamais lannion avec le show plein et
toute l'équipe s'est généreusement
offert quelques minutes de leur temps en
bas des marches et pour connaître une
peine je sais qu'ils parlent pas
beaucoup à la presse donc c'est un petit
peu exceptionnel convient d'avoir
[Musique]
convoi mélanie laurent ou de rouge vêtue
mylène farmer dans une très belle robe
noire
et harry
non merci
[Musique]
on va peut-être essayé de parler avec
lui
[Musique]
d'autres vend de l'équipement bonne on
va laisser monter tranquillement les
marges se mettre en place on parlera
vous reverrez today et sonore les
interviews de champagne et de son équipe
demain puisqu'il ya la conférence de
presse à me semble t'il 11h30 c'est ça
oui
je n'aurais
la mode a manqué 11h30 c'est ça oui les
protocoles
avec pierre et hélène 11h15 vivrait la
journée de de flacq dès le jour du
drapeau à quelques semaines avant elle
n'est pas nouvelle
traditionnellement les
l'âge et les villes américaines des
petites villes en général où tout le
monde s'habille en drapeau américain
avec des casquettes des fonds
la montée des marches de mélanie laurent
tahar rahim et mylène farmer est
terminée et sont accueillis comme tous
les soirs par le président du festival
et à lescure et son délégué général
thierry frémaux et une dernière photo en
haut des marches
[Musique]
voilà vous voyez là haut
les trois jurés
de ce festival les jurés en droit de
faire la montée des marches de ne pas la
faire de passer par derrière de passer
par de grands vins sont chez de la
méiose mcgee qui vient d'arriver en
cachette avec son épouse en bas des
marches on va essayer de montrer l'image